good morning Hank it's Sunday it's
Newsday and that means it's time to get
on board the fail boat with our intrepid
captain the dread pirate fireball Wilson
Roberts Hank the fail boat is of course
the puppy captain questionably seaworthy
vessel that we nerdfighters use to
transport ourselves around the various
islands of our our Kapoeta empire known
as nerdfighteria and that we also used a
sail around the world learning about
places currently experiencing world suck
where to first skipper
Willie says aye Italia yes Hank first
we're sailing the fail boat off to Italy
and then walking eight miles inland to
the Vatican where there has lately been
quite a lot of hullabaloo over a certain
quasi bishop named Richard Williamson
hey Richard Williamson is a crazy person
who until recently was excommunicated
from the Catholic Church on account of
his being crazy but then recently Pope
Benedict lifted the excommunication so
that they could possibly begin the
process of rehabilitating this dude into
the church so he could be a bishop again
and a lot of people are upset about this
because Richard Williamson has
repeatedly denied that the Holocaust
involved the murder of six million Jews
now thanks to the public outcry
Williamson has agreed to reconsider the
historical evidence of the Holocaust
which is like reconsidering the historic
evidence that America had a president
called Ronald Reagan so my guess is that
Richard Williamson wants to be a bishop
and so he's going to say ok there was a
Holocaust I'm sorry
and then maybe he's going to get
rehabilitated which would be an error
because in addition to being a Holocaust
denier Richard Williamson also has a lot
of crazy beliefs like for instance that
women should not be allowed to go to
college and perhaps most importantly
Richard Williamson believes that women
should not be allowed to wear pants mr.
Williamson when you try to take away our
ladies pants we here in nerdfighteria
take that quite personally let me
explain something to you sir
the book title everything that rises
must converge in your pants is funny the
book title everything that rises must
converge in the 19th century hoop skirt
that was designed explicitly to limit
your movements and thereby rob you of
your power is not funny and Roger
Williamson you bishop Brno will not take
away my in your pants jokes next up on
the road Oh captain fireball do you have
something you want to say to would be
Bishop Williamson
oh my you tiny white fluffy pirate sure
do have dirty mouths I wouldn't have
used those words but I do agree with the
sentiment where to next Oh captain my
captain very well then full speed ahead
to Australia and just because it's cold
at your house doesn't mean global
warming is a lie news the deadliest
wildfires in the history of Australia
are currently raging in the south of the
country so Hank for the last little
while it has been really hot and really
dry and really windy in Australia like
117 degrees Fahrenheit hot and these
conditions have combined with what is in
at least some cases apparent arson to
create epically horrible wildfires
hundreds of square miles of wilderness
has burned entire towns have been
destroyed and many people have lost
their lives thank you and I have many
friends and fellow nerdfighters who when
they are not wintering in nerdfighteria
lived in southern Australia I know that
we're both concerned about them and I
hope that they know that our thoughts
and prayers are with them Hank this is
yourself or possibly a me wearing a you
costume in an attempt to cheer up
Australian nerdfighters for captain
fireball Roberts and the whole crew of
the fail boat this is Hank green saying
best wishes
why yes I do also have a me disguise by
the way thank you to the nerdfighter who
made this but why did I get kim jong
il's haircut